thank you thank you very much thank you
very much Dean Gus Speth the Dino of the
school of Forestry and environmental
studies yet year a friend of many years
a pharaoh environmentalist for many many
years we struggled and then in the year
2000 I had the privilege of being
invited by the Dean an year to come here
and share my experiences of working at
grassroots level for the environment
with the students of forests in
environmental studies it was a most
important part of my life never in my
dreams did I think I would ever step
have my steps here at year I didn't have
the credentials but bring you here at
here that I can tell you and so for me
it was such a great honor and such a
great privilege and I have a lyric
changed in my life because when I was
here it was like I was going to college
all over again and although i was
sharing my experience with the students
i was learning more than they were
learning from me i was running from them
and indeed from their wonderful and
exceptional academic environment here at
Yale I still talk to people about it
especially when I'm talking in Nairobi
or in the Kenya in East Africa trying to
tell people that you can hardly you can
really not quite understand the spirit
of Yale until you come here and you stay
here and you share that spirit and I
want to thank the Dean and yellow
community for having given me that
opportunity to be here for those six six
months during that time I shared the
experience of how i started the green
belt movement really not started a
movement when I first started I was in
starting a movement I was starting up
project because it was nineteen
seventy-four and the world was preparing
to go to Mexico for the very fast
international conference UN
international conference on women it was
those women in Mexico in 1975 who
declared the women decayed 75 to 85 and
85 to 95 in 85 they came to Nairobi and
they decided eternia's was not enough so
they declared another decade and in 95
they went to Berlin and then they
decided they will they were from
henceforth celebrate from New York so
the women have been meeting ever since
but every one of the women who
participated in those very momentous
times in the seventies really have seen
how the world has changed as
opportunities for the girl child has
changed but during that time we we are
listening and planning how we would go
to Mexico and I was listening as a
member of the National Council of women
of Kenya where all women from all
aspects met and although I went there as
a member of the academic women academic
in the University of Nairobi with my own
baggage as a woman academician
struggling to make a place for me in the
University in a very male-dominated
institution when I got to the National
Council women and listened to the women
talking I realized that they were
talking about very basic needs they were
talking about food how do we get
adequate food nutritious food how do we
get clean drinking water how do we get
energy which is the main source which is
firewood even to this day the main
source
of energy for neuro populations how do
we put money in our pockets women said
even though many of them came from areas
where they were growing cash crops these
cash crops are registered in the name of
their male partners husbands fathers and
therefore the money was not going into
the woman's pockets so women we are
wondering how do we get ourselves some
income in our pockets these were the
issues that the women we are raising and
then I realized that what I was really
talking about as an academic member of
staff was very was I was pursuing luxury
I was pursuing lugs alley when these
women who represented more than seventy
percent of the population we are
pursuing needs basic needs so my
emphasis changed and I started out
asking the women that we do something I
don't know why I did that I sometimes
think that when you have spent years in
the university you learn to solve
problems that's what men mainly we learn
in the university's i think is to solve
problems we have already learned how to
read and write so we are trying to learn
how do you solve problems and we hope
that when you we go out there we can be
part and parcel of the world that solves
problems for humanity so I as I was
thinking to the women I thought well how
do you solve the problems that the women
are talking about they're talking about
an environment an environment that is
degraded an environment that has lost a
lot of its forests an environment that
is quickly losing its clean drinking
water an environment that is losing its
top soil and the capacity to produce
food an environment that is not able to
sustain their rural populations
so what we need to do is rehabilitate
this environment and immediately I
thought of a tree and i'm quite sure
it's because i had done biology in
college and ecosystems where a natural
way of thinking so I thought if we have
trees we will hold the soil in place so
we'll stop soil erosion we will give the
women firewood and if we plant fruit
trees who give them food with a
supplement their diets and because we
are in the tropics and trees grow very
fast they will be able to sell and
within five to ten years they can put
money in their pocket I also thought
that we can also be creative if these
women grow trees and plant them on their
farms if they can make those trees
survive which is the biggest challenge
for those who planted trees then we
could compensate these women for every
tree that survives and that would help
put money in their pockets and but I
needed the money so I started asking for
my my friends to give me money many of
them were not reached prams so I started
realizing but to make those women we
have an incentive something to sustain
the interest before I could get them
together and educate them on the need to
do it not only because it's good for
them but also because it's good for the
country's good for them for the future
generations I will look for money and I
will compensate the women for every tree
that survives and at that time we were
talking about a small project in the
National Council of women but gradually
it emerged that this was a great need
that there was a great interest that
people wanted to plant the trees but
they did not know how because we had
come to believe that only foresters can
plant the trees and God of course
and God was in planting fast enough for
us that's when planting fast enough so
we thought the women need to come in and
help and in the beginning the Foresters
had a problem because our forests are
actually trained to establish commercial
plantations this is a problem we have
even today as part of our environmental
issues in our country but we have
foresters who are trained to establish
commercio plantations of trees that are
mainly from the northern hemisphere or
the southern hemisphere mostly from the
southern hemisphere is the eucalyptus
and in the northern hemisphere is the
pines these trees grow on the mountains
so when the British came and they were
trying to develop the colony they
established a system which has now
become a problem because they came and
they clear-cut they didja nurse forests
and they replaced them with these exotic
plantations and the forestry school is
largely producing managers of such
plantations and the first thing that
comes to these foresters is money how to
make money from when they see a tree
they see timber and they see timber
industry furniture industry building
industry they don't see conservation
conservation is something that is only
now trying very hard to creep into their
thinking to a very large extent they
just think about these plantations
unfortunately these plantations once you
establish them because you have to have
as to the trees every so many years let
us say 30 years 40 years 50 years
maximum these plantations become farms
of trees and a farm of monoculture
cannot play the
same row cannot provide the same
services as an ecological system as God
intended it to be as it was created an
ecological system that embraces plants
animals insects birds when if you go
into a monoculture forest in our part of
the world you will not hear anything
except the wind there are no bees there
are no birds there are no animals only
humans occasionally who have come to see
how the trees are doing and so we have a
very big problem of trying to educate
not only our governments our ministers
but also our foresters and now the
communities living near the forest who
have come to appreciate these
monocultures because they are invited
into the forest they cultivate food
crops in the forest and as they
cultivate the forest as plant the
monoculture trees and when there is too
much shade they move away and they go to
another area so it becomes like a
shifting cultivation as we call it there
non-residential cat evasion and for
those of you who may know about this
system it's a is competing very strongly
with the issue of conservation we are
trying to say that these forests where
encroached upon they were encroached
upon by the British foresters at a time
when they didn't know better the issue
of conservation the issue of environment
was not there been the issue was how do
you provide the timber to a new colony
that needs to develop very fast so to
try to bring in an understanding that
we need a conservation as well as
development that we need to manage the
forest as they are sustainably and so
that we can get the services from these
forests is a very major challenge and
the services that we need very much
especially within Africa is water and
then for much of Africa depends on
agriculture and many rivers come from
these mountains with the climate change
snow is melting ice is melting from the
mountains and more and more of these
rivers are drying up and the volume is
decreasing to the point that ordinary
people can see with the naked eye but
this river was flowing fast 5 10 years
ago now it's dry white maybe it is not
the climate change but maybe it is that
what we are doing to the forests so we
are extremely charged and I would hope
that some of the studies that could be
done by the by the students here maybe
masters even PhDs is to try to see how
some of these systems really adda mine
development sustainable development
because I was just sharing with with a
group of leadership members the members
of the leadership council over lunch
that the fact that Kenya for example is
already rated a water scarce country so
for anybody to come and introduce a
system that other minds the services of
water from these forests or other mines
the rain for patterns in this region to
me is very short-sighted yet a minister
of government just the other day and I'm
sure that point was directed at me
because I'm I'm holding all the time
about
this system at home he said it is very
difficult for a country like Kenya to do
without this system the commercial
plantations now I'm sure he's thinking
about today and his probable is
responding to pressure from that they
industry rather than thinking long term
about the need for water and a need for
dependable reliable lane for patterns in
a country that needs that that relies so
heavily on now on length on agriculture
and therefore I want to say that my time
here at you really helped me focus very
keenly on them connection between what
we run in school very intensive learning
but what is happening on the ground that
you can have a PhD you can have a
master's you can be very landed but at
the same time what is happening at the
ground is a de-mining all that you know
is good for the country for the world
and it is for that reason that I enjoy
being able to touch the ground retain
that green belt movement be able to go
to the ground work with the women try to
persuade them that it is very important
for them to plant trees on their farms
and not depend on trees from the forest
try to persuade that minister and that
minister by the way it has a degree in
agriculture believe it or not it is also
for that reason that we continue to
inspire people to get involved not to
just learn but to get involved and in
2006 you remember we launched a campaign
to plant a billion trees and we asked
the Prince of Monaco to be part of the
patrons for the campaign it's it
supported by the United Nations and
program and a craft which is the
international center for agroforestry
and the green belt movement did we think
that we could plant a billion trees ah
well okay we thought try it and it was
very wonderful to see how governments
ecology students high school students
even kindergarten kids got involved and
everywhere people were talking about
lettuce plant a tree of course a billion
trees may still be a drop in the ocean
because of all the problems that we face
in the world but the important thing is
it was aware of raising awareness that
indeed we have a problem with our
environment and it is not so much
because we don't know we have all the
information a lot of information we
ought to be very much involved but we
are not the right decisions should be
made in our offices in our capitals in
our government offices but they are not
being made because perhaps there is not
adequate awareness among the citizens in
order to put pressure on the leaders
because you know leaders I don't know
about you here but in my part of the
world if you if we don't put pressure on
there on the leaders they will get away
with the man right they can but citizens
are the ones who eventually make their
leaders change this is why it is so
important to have such a campaign as
billion tree campaign is to engage the
ordinary people engage citizens in every
country and of course we also had a lot
of governments that were participating
and by last year when people met in Bali
which was almost a year after we
launched the campaign lo and behold we
reached the billion tree campaign even
before we got to Bali
and it was really wonderful to be able
to announce anybody that our people in
the world had indeed planted more than a
billion three trees worldwide Oh problem
and I think people are having a lot of
fun doing it because they decided they
didn't want the party to end they say we
continue so we are now into our second
billion and I know that there are people
who are only now discovering about the
campaign so we are hoping that people
will continue to be excited and to be
involved and I was very happy as as we
are coming in with so some students
there who said that they are involved
that they have registered and you know
you can get on two billion Terry
campaign through the United Nations the
United a unit website or you can also
use the greenbelt website and green belt
movement one word dotto ROG and you can
be connected to the video entry campaign
and register you were three even if it's
only 13 register it be part of that
great global party and that is really
very very wonderful I also now want to
say something about the nobel peace
prize after spreading that wonderful
time here at year and getting those were
wonderful recognitions and decorations
from president levin and the entire
community of year i guess people notice
to me i guess they had not noticed me
before but they noticed there was this
woman who was in hell and and she got a
degree from here who is she so they
looked into the issue and lo and behold
and 2004 they come and they say wow what
she has been doing is very very
interesting and those of you who may
have studied the nobel peace prize
history it has now about a hundred years
history the committee always wants to
bring out an issue that they think is
extremely important to the world that
they think needs the attention of the
entire world and in the beginning they
were dealing with the issues that had
direct connect direct connection with
wars and a piece like bringing people
who have been fighting together
negotiating peace but later on they
started recognizing issues that can
actually add a mind piece that issues
that if they are not addressed there can
be no peace and that's why they shifted
and started for example recognizing what
many of us I'm sure no human rights for
a long time nobody was talking about
human rights but the Norwegian committee
made a shift and recognized people like
Martin Luther King people like Nelson
Mandela des moody 22 de klerk people who
were very much involved in human rights
issues and suddenly the human rights
issues became the issue of the world and
now people who are other mining human
rights issues are alone in the world and
they have a lot of pressure on them
please we want to put a lot of pressure
until the whole world recognizes that
all of us have rights and we are even
beginning to move into the next name of
right that all forms of life should be
protected they have right a right to be
that species should that we should not
allow for example species to be hunted
to extinction or poisoned to extension
or eaten to extinction but they have a
right to be and then in 2004 the
committee decided that the issue of
environment had to become a very big
issue and it was touching or aspects of
our life that it was
no longer just an issue for a view a few
crazy people who love butterflies and
beef that it is an issue that if it is
not attended to it can add a mind peace
and what we had been trying to say is
that it is very important for us to
recognize that the planet we live in at
the moment has very limited resources we
are very many we compete for these
resources if we are not able to manage
these resources in a responsible way in
an accountable way we will fight over
them if we are not able to share these
resources in a more equitable way we
will fight those who feel marginalized
those who feel excluded will eventually
rise up and create chaos as they seek
for justice and the one way in which we
can make sure that this happens is if we
can govern ourselves through a political
and economic system that allows that to
be possible and such a system for lack
of better word today we like to say is
more democratic it's a system that
respects the root respects human rights
of all it's a system that is transparent
as much as politicians can make it
transparent it's a system that is
accountable where leaders are
accountable to those they read it's a
system where people are allowed to
decide who will govern over them who
will be in charge of these resources
because for many of these readers when
you put them in positions of authority
and I can tell you without hesitation
that in our part of the world we still
are fighting that basic understanding
that leaders have that when you put them
in positions
of authority they think you have given
them full ownership of all the resources
on the land and they think they can do
with those resources as they please but
the reality is they are custodians they
need to understand that they are
custodians and they are managing those
resources on our behalf now we need a
system a political system an economic
system that gives us an opportunity to
hold them accountable and that system as
I say we call it democratic but it can
be translated in many ways according to
where people are but basically we all
recognize that it is a system that
promotes justice fairness respects the
diversity that is part of our human
family and the committee wanted to
emphasize therefore that we need to work
by pre-empting the reasons why we go to
war pre-empting the causes of conflict
and that is true whether you are talking
about a small country like Kenya which
as you all know was in a conflict since
generally and this conflict was actually
driven by inequitable distribution of
Vlad resource in Kenya and generally of
opportunities in Kenya and therefore
creates a very large number of were
people very unhappy people who were very
easily incited by politicians who
suddenly lost elections or were made to
lose elections and so if we want to live
in peace this is what the Nobel
Committee message was if we want to live
in peace we have to preempt the causes
of conflict work backwards and that is
the message that was given in 2004 and I
was
privileged honored to be the carrier of
that message and I've been carrying that
message everywhere I go and one of the
challenges that we are now facing faced
with is of course the challenge of
climate change which is being addressed
very adequately by the former vice
president ago who as you know also got
about a nobel peace prize by because of
his capacity to be able to bring to our
attention that indeed some of the
activities that we are carrying out our
other mining our capacity to survive on
this planet and some of those capacities
come activities are being driven by need
some are being driven by greed and so it
is necessary for us to recall the words
of march magadi that there is enough for
every month need remember i started this
campaign to meet the 30 needs of women
when it is need it can be met but it's
very difficult to meet and to satisfy
agreed and we need to fight that
wherever we come across it sometimes it
takes it demonstrates itself very open
it sometimes it doesn't and so the
climate change issue has driven us to
campaign for the protection of forests
and I'm very happy to be to have
accepted an invitation by the heads of
states of the of the Central African
countries ten countries who came
together and they said they said that
they want to protect the Congo forest
ecosystem and I was very happy to meet
somebody from the Congo DRC that's one
of the countries that have come together
and they formed a partnership
along with other donors mainly from
Europe also America to try to protect
that ecosystem that is one of the three
main lungs as we know for the world the
others are the amazon and the southeast
asia forests all of them are a lot of
pressure from countries especially the
emerging developing countries that have
a huge hunger for raw materials and raw
materials in form of logs are really
undermining all of these forests and
unless there is a strong campaign
worldwide to stop this appetite and
especially to educate the consumers so
that we demand that we shall only buy
wood from sustainably managed forests
these forests are going to be destroyed
not by the locals I can assure you the
Congo forest is not being other mind by
the pygmies who live in those forests it
is international trade that refuses to
listen to any voice that we can we can
raise and sometimes even refuses to
honour laws of the country recently I
was in Tanzania to launch a campaign to
protect forests and part of their horror
is fighting illegal logging of the
beautiful black mahogany in the southern
forests of Tanzania where you find
mountains of logs being cut largely by
the local people but being sold to
international boats that are literally
lining up along the coast to carry these
logs illegally because the government of
Tanzania says north blogs should live
Tanzania we should they should all be
add value added so that the government
can get revenue but with this kind of
illegal logging
is virtually impossible for us to save
forest and without such huge carbon
sinks I do not know how we shall be able
to bring down the climate let alone
sustained and I won't therefore to say
that I'm very happy to be goodwill
ambassador of of this forest and I go
around trying to raise awareness about
it and the last time I I was i won the
year of the British government and the
British government through the current
prime minister committed one hundred
million dollars to a fund to protect the
Congo forest which I think we should
thank the British government for for
doing that I know we do not have much
time and I know you may want to ask some
questions but I do want to say that
being here at year and and and going
through the beautiful and wonderful very
unleashing academic experience that you
have I think that it would be wonderful
for the students to go out and
experience I know it is expensive and I
know sometimes it's very difficult to
implement that but I will never forget
that when I was here gas is fed managed
to get resources for us to be able to go
to Kenya with the class that I was
sharing with and they were so impressed
in fact they came back and they said
that they learnt more in the field that
they had than they had lunch in the
classroom and I wish that you would have
an opportunity to have that experience
if you have an opportunity take
advantage of it but in the meantime
especially when you any college it is an
especially such as this College gives
you so many opportunities to get
involved do get involved even if it is
in simple activities like recycling you
know that the
the three our campaign that I actually
learned from this country reuse reduce
recycle I'm sure you can all think of
something that you can do to reuse the
day before yesterday or was it yesterday
actually we were in a courage in ecology
in Geneva hobart and william smith and i
was very impressed by some of the
activities they are doing they have come
up with the innovative activities such
as traveling with bikes within the
compass is a small compass may not be
able to do a chat here where you have
such a big population but they have
bicycles which they ride and you leave
it where ever you are going and then
when you are ready to go you take
another bike to cut it down on cars they
also have mugs so that they can use the
mugs instead of paper and I was very
impressed I got some bunch of letters
from kindergarten kids and some of them
told me that they no longer when they
watch their hands they said when I
watched my hands I don't use paper I use
the red raha so that I do not create
garbage I thought this is great and this
is a kindergarten so there are lots of
creative things that we can do in
college and we can encourage in our
communities in order to promote that
reuse reduce recycle idea and some of
these ideas of course look very very
simple-minded but they form they help us
form a habit and especially because you
will be amazed many people look up to
you you are the examples you are the
epitome of what people want to do to be
and tomorrow you will be in the biggest
offices you will be the next president
you will be the next judges the next
lawyers you
will feel the offices in Washington and
in every capital of the world and most
people look at what America does and as
you know many people we are always
hiding behind president bush and saying
well he didn't sign a kyoto protocol so
why should we sign and I know therefore
that what you do matters what this
country decides matters because so many
others look to see what this country
decides so if you provide the leadership
and i know i'm talking to the people who
are either providing it or will be
providing it tomorrow then you know that
you are not only doing it for America
you are not only doing it for your
community you are doing it for the whole
world and i want to add my comments with
a short story that some of you may have
had me talk about and i want to give
this little story because i know that
sometimes you talk like this and people
fear not now what am i supposed to do
the issues are so huge so the ice is
melting in the polar regions what am I
supposed to do it's melting in the
Himalayas in Nyakairima John what am I
supposed to do the desert is spreading
Africa is supposed to be the one most
negatively impacted by the climate what
am I supposed to do where is the green
belt movement they're supposed to be
planting trees well sometimes you can
get overwhelmed and sometimes I actually
do get overwhelmed you know people think
I have a solution to the problems I
don't I saw when they come to me as a
plant a tree but I have a little story
that sometimes I even talk to myself and
it's a story of a fire that broke out in
this huge beautiful forest and it was
raging and all the animals came out of
the forest and they felt overwhelmed by
the fire the third completely powerless
and they just stood there war
she the fire edge accepted this little
hummingbird it said I'm going to do
something about the fire so it flew to
the nearest extreme took a drop of water
and came and put it on the fire and ran
back to the liver and wrote another drop
and kept going up and down up and down
every time bringing a drop of water and
putting it on the raging fire in the
meantime the other animals are washing
wondering how stupid can anybody be how
does this bird think it can put off that
fire and they said what are you trying
to do you're too little your wings are
too little you have a little big you can
only bring a little drop of water at a
time but the bird wouldn't hear of it
just kept persistent emitted and some of
this but some of these animals had be
you know like the airmen had a big trunk
can go and bring a lot of water from the
liver and it just kept asking the
hummingbird she joined them what are you
trying to do and the little bird without
wasting any time turn to them and said
what I hope all of us can be able to say
to each other and threw ourselves
wherever we feel overwhelmed I'm doing
the best I can thank you very much